embrace too
goods
not the right way to go
well we went to film school where from
school that's the whole or what we're
taught nobody would dare as a professor
say oh you should guys you know you guys
should go make stuff on YouTube and just
put it on the Internet make whatever you
want it's fun nobody says that those are
not in our films not in our build school
in our film school it was make these
pieces of art send them to these
festivals and that was about the only
way to do it and so I mean everybody
everybody i think the left film school
at least where he went had that same
mentality of even though youtube sounds
fun you can't use his profession because
nobody has been talking to use it his
profession now looking back I think we
both agree if somebody had told us how
to use YouTube back five years ago we
could have been like phenomenally
successful like without living trying
anymore because we just would have come
in at the right time at the begin of the
gold rush of YouTube as a new medium and
that I think was really important it's
still available medium it's just now
everybody's figured it out it's
saturated so it's a little harder now I
think that it was but knowing that I
could have spent explain over four years
making YouTube videos instead of state
of classrooms going to make films and go
out to felt paying a ton of money and
owing a lot of people more interest and
I would never sent a thing to a festival
either so all that strategy I've never
even done I have I didn't get accepted
very often once like one
now we know that over a year you can
make a youtube channel 22 million views
which I could never get from customer
yeah
you live and you learn so the answer is
we disagree with it okay why did you
guys choose this route why did you
choose youtube / sort of the traditional
filmmaking bro personal taste i think i
can personally i'm just not too
interested in i do parody stuff in
musical numbers and things like that
comedy and stuff I know you can do that
in the festival circuit but having to
spend the money to do a proper film was
a proper film is so much harder to come
up with then being able to work on
YouTube with no budget and I can put it
up for free and all it takes from me in
order to get it out to people is maybe
trying to get onto some blogs so send it
to a couple of video game websites and
say hey you've never seen something like
this take a look and video game websites
say you're right I've never seen that
before yeah i'm going to post this all
the people that come to my site all day
are going to be clicking on it watching
it sharing with their friends so I think
if I were into things that didn't have a
market on the internet I would have to
start looking at things like festivals
again but but luckily we do silly drama
things and I mean we do musical numbers
so it's like even if you're not
interested in watching our video you're
probably still in my tea interested in
just listening to it so we have a bunch
of subscribers we're just like yeah so I
threw this on my ipod and listen to it
every day in the car there's a we're
going to anime expo tomorrow and there
was like this group of cosplaying Final
Fantasy guys we're like so we downloaded
your your video onto our ipod we're
gonna be all singing it in the car as
we're driving in in the final fantasy
cosplay to anime expo yeah so it's a
totally different mentality then film
have been a you know film festival or
traditional medium where it's like you
go here you watch the thing and it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't leave that
area whereas with you with YouTube I
feel like we're getting more of this
interactivity yeah yeah
action
you